foreign
[Music]
you've said that the meaning of life is
to win
if you look five years into the future
what does winning look like
so
I there's a lot of I can go into like
technical depth to what I mean by that
to win
um it may not mean I was criticized for
that in the comments like doesn't this
guy want to like save the penguins in
Antarctica or like okay you know listen
to what I'm saying I'm not talking about
like I have a yacht or something yeah
I am an agent
I am put into this world
and
I don't really know what my purpose is
but if you're a reinforcement if you're
if you're an intelligent agent and
you're put into a world what is the
ideal thing to do well the ideal thing
mathematically you can go back to like
Schmidt hover theories about this is to
uh build a compressive model of the
world to build a maximally compressive
to explore the world such that your
exploration function
maximizes the derivative of compression
of the past mid Hooper has a paper about
this and like I took that kind of as
like a personal goal function
um so what I mean to win I mean like
maybe maybe this is religious but like I
think that in the future I might be
given a real purpose or I may decide
this purpose myself and then at that
point now I know what the game is and I
know how to win I think right now I'm
still just trying to figure out what the
game is but once I know
so you have uh you have uh imperfect
information you have a lot of
uncertainty about the reward function
and you're discovering it exactly what
the purpose is that's a better way to
put it the purpose is to maximize it
while you have it uh a lot of
uncertainty around it and you're both
reducing the uncertainty and maximizing
at the same time yeah and uh so that's
at the technical level what is the if
you believe in the Universal prior yeah
what is the universal reward function
that's the better way to put it
so that win is interesting I think I
speak for everyone
in saying that I wonder what that reward
function is
for you and uh I look forward to seeing
that in five years and 10 years I think
a lot of people including myself for
cheering you on man so I'm I'm happy you
exist and I wish you the best of luck